on vous a souvent montré depuis le début
de la pandémie
ces images tournées par des citoyens de
salles d'attentes vide dans les urgences
des hôpitaux car son four eu ce soi
disant manque d'achalandage est la
preuve que les gouvernements et les
médias mentent que la crise sanitaire
n'existe pas cet argument démontre une
méconnaissance de la réalité vécue ou
feront dans les zones chaudes
là où se joue vraiment la guerre contre
la copie 19 ans on vous propose donc
aujourd'hui une incursion dans la zone
chaude de l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont
à montréal en compagnie du chef des
soins intensifs
le docteur françois marquis vous verrez
le contraste est frappant
enfin l'entrée de la zone chaude les
deux unités dédiées aux kebabs
on voit ici la porte n'a tri de sas
tous nos spas saint-cyr sont très connu
et très malade
on est ici un de coiffeur porte l'homme
un bastien covin très malade qu'on a la
machine de dialyse à gauche on a les
respirateurs les diffuseurs de nous la
nourriture les moniteurs des centres et
si depuis plusieurs semaines on a ici
nos autres patients corinne on note que
quelques élites libres sont
malheureusement faux utilisable parce
que l'on n'a pas assez de personnel pour
les ouvrir même présentement ou dessus
de notre capacité
la deuxième raison qui décidez
c'est un peu mon dos
ou comme et si lui aussi depuis
plusieurs jours
marseille - le tout les champs sont
occupées par tous on a des champions
des patients comme pas d'accord marquis
merci de nous avoir permis de voir
l'envers de la médaille quand vous
entendez j'imagine que de la vendre a dû
souvent les urgences on ride
les gouvernements nous manque les
autorités sanitaires aussi qu'est ce que
vous pensez à chaque voyage on entend
souvent parler qui avait beaucoup de
gens qui venaient en ville mais pourrait
rien à l'urgence pour des petits bobos
qui réduit pris en charge par des
médecins de famille dans des cliniques
externes des choses comme ça ce qu'on
voit présentement six à quoi pourrait
ressembler nos urgences
c'est à dire que les gens qui ont
maintenant une peur atroce la colline ne
se présente pas pour eux rien à
l'urgence
ça nous amène la problèmes que ceux qui
se présentent sont excessivement malade
et ne passe pas par la salle d'attenté
ils vont passer directement par les
ambiances et ce qu'on ne voit pas ce que
les gens ne voient pas parce qu'il se
plante pas ici en comptant les
ambulances c'est l'augmentation
importante du nombre de lancements ne
sais pas si on le demande tellement de
ressources qui compte pour un deux trois
patients des fois s'y colle pour trois
patients mais ça veut dire que deux lits
à quelque part qui vont être fermées
donc ça peut paraître paradoxal il ya
délit de libre pourquoi parce qu'on n'a
pas assez de gens pour ce cri de tous
les patients malades pas parce qu'on
veut fermer des lignes personne qui veut
fermer des lits canton par exemple
votre délester et on coupe les salles
d'opération mais c'est certain que si
quelqu'un se promène dans la section qui
est dédié à la chirurgie d'un jour
ben c'est un grand espace vide parce
qu'en neuf une chirurgie d'un jour
lorsque je vous propose de faire marquer
c'est que je vais vous je vous évoquez
certaines de ces fausses nouvelles jomby
qu'on les appelle celle qui refuse de
mourir dans le contexte la kobe 19 cas
passez vous des gens qui disaient qu'ils
affirment
où sont les autopsies je les vois pas
laisser louche on fait une autopsie pour
deux raisons améliorer le traitement des
prochains qui auront cette maladie là où
apprendre à connaître la maladie
il ya eu un million de morts avec l'aco
vide
les autopsies qu'on a eu à faire ont
toutes été faites au début on n'a juste
pas besoin d'une autopsie et demander
des autopsies
quand ce n'est pas nécessaire c'est non
éthique et c'est un grand manque de
respect pour les patients et leurs
familles des gens qu'ils vont payer
schéma 3 % des décès qui sont réellement
attribuable à la corvée du neuf celle là
je laime bien parce que je peux voir
vous aviez c'est la question des
comorbidités c'est que les gens vont
dire aïe et pas mal de covin il y avait
du diabète et d'hypertension
ok mais ce diabète et cette hypertension
là auraient été contrôlés encore pendant
10 ans 20 ans ou 30 ans on peut pas dire
que c'est ce que c'est le diabète ou
l'hypertension qui a causé le décès est
un exemple que je donne là dessus
imaginez que vous êtes un diabétique
vous avez un accident d'auto si vous
êtes membre l'accident d'auto est-ce que
les gens trouveraient normal que je
marque comme cause de décès diabète
ben non ils mordent rex temps de taux
s'il n'avait pas eu ces textes-là d'auto
là il y aurait sept personnes auraient
vécu c'est claque au vide est un
accident virologiques
c'est à dire qu'on fait notre vie on
attrape la cage vide oui nous comme une
automobiliste et vont avoir un impact à
savoir à quel point notre corps va être
pitié pour se défendre mais la cause des
décès de mères détection à coville et
ceux qui dit à g graphiques à l'appui
dix ans pas plus grave qu'une grippe
saisonnière regarder les chiffres
je ne sais pas d'où ils prennent leurs
chiffres ou comment ils traitent leurs
chiffres
mais c'est pas con
on a juste à compter les émissions
je n'ai jamais vu en 20 antérieur et me
mets mes collègues plus âgés n'ont
jamais vu des étages v10 à la grippe
saisonnière
jusqu'à quel point ça nuit à votre
travail cette désinformation la très
concrètement ben concrètement c'est un
extraordinaire saboteurs de morale parce
que quand les gens se donne jour et nuit
sont des quarts de travail qui ont plus
de sens qu'on s'est enlevé notre accès à
nos familles à nos loisirs à nos
vacances et qu'on se fait dire qu'on
feint que tout cela n'est pas vrai s'est
détruit complètement à l'intérieur cette
envie d'aider le prochain puis de dénis
pourquoi on fait ce sacrifice là de
façon plus étendu ce qui est encore pire
c'est que ça ne crée des nouveaux coop
qui vont expliquer par ces gens là de
tout sauf de façon farfelue
on a des gens qui sont leurs lignes man
ou zombies qu'il n'avait pas la copie
que c'était progrès le bien entendu je
l' ai entendu des familles qui ont
complètement ni à toute la famille
positif pour l'accueil de leurs proches
est en train de mourir en sommes et
c'est pour nous autres qui a donné ça
c'est un gouvernement je livrerai du on
l'entend questions réponses un rendu là
je pense que je réponds plus sourit je
m'occupe du patient moi je suis là pour
le patient vous vous êtes là pour
rétablir les faits on travaille ensemble
mais ça sert à rien de rentrer dans un
argumentaire maugein spécial occuper ce
qui m'a rendu très choquée c'est la fois
où j'ai vu de mes yeux vu une
travailleuse la santé qui rentrait à
travers leur chance ça faisant fi de
toutes les précautions pourra la voir sa
mère qui était malade la colline en
disant qu'elle n'avait pas le covin que
c'était tout dans notre tête et alors
traversé l'urgence en équipement
protection ouvre toutes les portes avec
les boutons de ce qu a fait contaminer
la moitié de l'argent ce le temps que
les gardes de sécurité arrive
soc ça c'est la fois où j'étais beaucoup
moins compréhensifs
en bout de ligne il ya beaucoup qu'on va
apprendre sur nous mêmes et sur notre
société quand
5 et tout ça dans quelques années quand
vas-y mon doux seigneur je peux pas
croire que ces choses-là sont dites mais
entre-temps ils se disent il faut les
combattre la désinformation est un autre
style de virus qu'il faut combattre pour
lesquels les soins intensifs peuvent
plus ou pas je suppose merci beaucoup de
temps